now some ladies with this everything
about effort likewise the effort doesn't
matter when I go to work are you talking
about through the effort of dreaming I
just want to make sure when I'm talking
about ladies I'm not talking about white
women y'all never wrong everybody else
we believe you women don't worry about
but everybody else ladies so explain to
me the effort [ __ ] right cuz like for
some reason effort that that like going
to work is not effort but like when you
write a card like I just like the effort
or like oh you went and got this
specific thing or you made me a collage
or like you win and found like my
favorite pop-tart you're like there's
all these things right and I'm starting
to believe it's not effort is just
inconvenience it's like that's what you
equate love is like is it bothersome
yeah
is that love being bothered by devil's
advocate and I mean Devils if your girl
orders food for you or cooks food for
you yeah which one means more the exact
same real talk which I want taste better
the exact same Wow the exact matter of
fact I'm gonna get [ __ ] up for even
saying it you will be sick nah let me
not say this easy saying if I'm being
completely honest I really I love the
fact that she cooks because my girl
cooks all the time yeah I love the fact
that she's great it's great the food is
there etc it's amazing sometimes she
orders in
and she'll order in it she'll take it
off the plate or take it out of the box
and put on the plate mrs. Doubtfire
style yeah
that [ __ ] is lit what he not the box do
you care honestly I'm okay you know what
it is it's like struggle in America it's
that same 100-meter dash if she cooks at
home Usain Bolt mm-hmm you know if she
orders in Tim Montgomery it's close
mm-hmm I know Tim Montgomery they know I
like it when she cooks but if she was
like I'd rather just order and I'm
totally cool with that I just like the
fact that she put she back he puts Sun
Devil ain't always wrong yeah and what
do we say believe all women believe in
bro this is the effort no it's not the
effort I like I think I get it now yo
cuz if my girl made the dinner or she
bought a super expensive dinner it's
really the fact that there was dinner
there when I got home yeah it's not that
she pay for it mm-hmm right right that
makes sense right
and they would love a really nice card
or like a thoughtful date we like you
pay attention to a story she told you
one time and then like there was that
there so I see okay I'm starting to
understand a little bit now I ain't
gonna do it no I ain't gonna do it
I my dad didn't do it
put in effort my dad would he was so
thorough in his convictions bro I don't
think he got my mom flowers on Mother's
Day one time wow that just wasn't his
thing like I think that just wasn't his
thing yeah but not that you care but he
was just like what's that about like I
love you every single day like whatever
you talk about your mom she also seems
very practical as well so she did yeah
she plans about okay yeah sure yeah
thinking I get some flowers on Mother's
Day be even if she got a buck yeah now
I'm [ __ ] thinking about it now I kind
of understand it a little bit huh do you
do care about that [ __ ]
yeah I really think about it with just
food but like with food that [ __ ] makes
sense bro yeah like if you cook for me
as opposed to getting me McDonald's so
mark told us the most fascinating thing
before we started recording I I think
hey girl throughout the entire year
incredible takes notes on people when
they're just talking about [ __ ] and like
if they mentioned something that they
want so then any time their birthday or
holiday comes around she can go to her
notes and get all the thoughtful things
that that person actually wanted uh-huh
she has notes about his family members
so a mark didn't even know what to get
his own family she goes to her notes in
her phone so mark looks like the
thoughtful guy got incredible that's
incredible son that's effort I mean
that's yeah that's gonna make for some
great presents then he gets credit for I
guess what I'm trying to say is I think
effort at work should also be calculated
in today I do like the way I see you
trying to fight just being a better
boyfriend I appreciate that but do you
understand what I'm saying like effort
is effort like hundred percent y'all
women have a lot more effort to give
because they're not working as much yeah
and I'd be thinking that all the time
like you want gifts
how about I work and you buy your own
[ __ ] how about that that's not a gift
how he just what he said I Connor
no I made actually he said if we're
going on the andrew's point where
there's like a touch don't do that
there's a total amount of effort shut
out exactly how you said it I feel
uncomfortable on the inside bro just
like I don't feel right I feel like I
just found out I'm a trainee man that
should feel real weird inside man
[Applause]